mon défi consiste à faire toutes les
gardes de France il y en a 3000 j'ai dû
en faire à peu près 2000 2500 et je
m'étais pas vraiment attaqué au garde de
la région parisienne que j'occupe mes
loisirs comme ça j'avais la journée je
me tiens mais je vais partir à Montereau
et puis je vais rentrer ce soir chez moi
à chaque fois que je voyage je vais
appeler SNCF Connect pour savoir en
grande ligne qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme
possibilité combien de temps il faut
pour voir s'il y a des retard c'est une
très très bonne application on utilise
d'une manière presque systématique matin
je suis venu de Paris il y avait des
trains directs entre autres qui
mettaient 28 27 minutes j'ai préféré
prendre l'omnibus qui mettait 48 minutes
je mets un point d'honneur à m'arrêter
dans toutes les gares sur une ligne
quand je suis sur la région parisienne
j'utilise plus du tout ma voiture ça
fait des voitures en moins sur la route
c'est que logiquement certainement plus
intéressant de défis je l'ai commencé il
y a trois ans il a commencé dans les
Yvelines chez moi où j'habite et il se
terminera par la gare de Versailles Rive
Droite qui est la gare la plus ancienne
de France encore dans son jus 1837
pourquoi ce défi j'ai toujours fait
beaucoup de défis j'ai traversé la
France à pied j'ai fait le tour de la
France par les frontières en vélo ça
imprécie six mois en kayak je suis parti
de Paris à remonter la scène jusqu'à
Orléans je cherchais toujours des défis
un peu particulier les frères me dit
mais attends quand a été conçu les
parents avaient fumer de la moquette ou
quoi
Rochefort-sur-Mer avec marqué chemin de
Ferda qui est super nombreux bien
restaurer avec des mosaïques partout on
a l'impression de se croire
la grande mosquée istanbulent quoi ou
c'est vraiment très très surprenant les
lignes intéressantes que je dois faire
il y a encore pas mal de gares et de
lignes dans l'Est de la France autour de
Lyon Chambéry Annecy
et qu'est-ce que je fais dans le train
si vous l'avez pas posé comme question
je regarde à la fenêtre et je fais que
ça j'ai même fait quelques citations
regardez par la fenêtre n'est pas perdre
son temps c'est uniquement se perdre
dans ses rêves ça c'est moi qui l'ai
inventé